a los mayores de 65 años necesitarán una
tercera dosis para acceder a
restaurantes eventos culturales y trenes
en el país así lo expresó el presidente
manuel makoun en un mensaje a los
franceses instando a incrementar las
medidas de prevención contra el kobe 19
ante el aumento de las hospitalizaciones
el mandatario anunció que a partir del
15 de diciembre las vacunas de refuerzo
serán obligatorias para que los mayores
de 65 años sigan beneficiándose del pase
sanitario que habrá terceras dosis para
los mayores de 50 años recordando que la
efectividad de la vacuna decrece seis
meses después de inyectada desde el
final del verano se puso en marcha una
campaña para todos los mayores de 65
años y los más vulnerables y ahora hay
que acelerarla además se envió un
mensaje para los 6 millones de franceses
que han evitado la vacuna papel que les
recuerdo que los no vacunados tienen 11
veces más riesgo de terminar en el
hospital en cuidados intensivos
más allá de las cuestiones relacionadas
con kobe 19 emanuel makoun puso fin al
interminable rompecabezas de las
pensiones anunciando que no habrá
reforma dentro de su continuo debido a
la situación sanitaria actual en toda
europa
la necesidad de unidad en este momento
que vive nuestra nación hace que no se
den las condiciones para relanzar hoy
este proyecto finalmente al mismo tiempo
que instó a la inversión en energías
renovables macro anunció que francia
dará un impulso a la construcción de
nuevas centrales nucleares para según el
responder mejor a los crecientes
desafíos energéticos que afectan la
región